[Music]
katie used to be my little buddy
go on nature hikes skip rocks
are you excited for camp don't make me
go we used to be so connected hey dad
smile
you know you could experience things a
whole lot better without that camera
that this is how i experience things
yes tomorrow i'm finally leaving for
college but in the meantime i made you
guys this goodbye video you know what
this is our last night together
how about we make 10 seconds family eye
contact starting put your phone down
now no you're allowed to blink it's just
eye contact oh finally no screen's at
the table
linda why are you kicking me i don't
understand i'm just kidding oh look i'll
watch it dad it's too late look i want
to watch it
uh dad this is exactly why i'm excited
to leave tomorrow katie
i know you can fix this
why do you need all that to take me to
the airport i canceled your plane ticket
to college
we are going to drive you to school on a
cross-country road trip as a family
behold and now i present freaking rick
mitchell and kiss me dog
dang it dang it katie hey dad can you
check the trunk yeah sure
dang it katie hey kids there's supposed
to be some great hugs around here just a
second
we hear a pound about to drop our
biggest invention yet
meet the helper bot we promise you they
will never
ever turn even mom
what is that
greetings humans
technology rising up sayonara
robots roaming the streets what is this
strange creature
dog pig dog pig dog loaf of bread the
beaches have always been weird
no time to wash your hands don't worry i
never do that's what makes us great
that's my girl then we just might be
weird enough
to save the world all right hands in
oh he lit my tongue
[Music]
are you ready this is the main event
come get some of this uh-huh
who wants a selfie tentacular
i've got your whole life story tattooed
on my body
yeah in a long history of monster
wrestling there has never been a
champion quite like cynthia
fans around the world are asking is
there a challenger out there with the
hunger
the drive the discipline to become the
next
champion
ugh what all right i think that's enough
for today
steve might not look like much but there
is a champion monster inside of him
did he eat thank you
that felt great
[Applause]
we seriously need to work on strength
and endurance fortunately i know just
the thing
[Music]
what yeah that's going to be a hard no
for me
[Music]
oh do it again
[Music]
you got it oh boy this is my nightmare
[Music]
i love my life i love you so much gary
i'll never forget the day we met
[Music]
ready little snail what's your name
scary huh do you want to be friends
me too gary
i'm home gary bear
gary
[Music]
this summer the search begins friends
don't let friends go on
[Music]
hello call me sage good night i'm made
out of sage and i am a sage
so it works out pretty well i'm patrick
my name means
toaster in celtic pretty sure it doesn't
the most amazing places
the lost city of atlantic city boy i
hope we don't lose focus
look i wouldn't worry about us losing
[Music]
patrick that's not an l that's a seven
seven starts with an l
oh that's weird the spongebob movie
sponge on the run this is gonna be like
a buddy movie oh i love your sense of
irony patrick thank you
i love my sense of ironing too
[Music]
happy birthday mr adult man oh my
god was dad like
his beard was scratchy he had a goofy
laugh i wish i'd met him
[Music]
i have something for you from your dad
it's a wizard staff
i wrote this spell so i can see for
myself who my boys grew up to be
this spell brings him back back like
back to life
he wanted to meet you more than anything
bowie tooth of zadar how did you i don't
know
dad you are in your house
we've only got 24 hours to bring back
the rest of dad
we're going on a quest
all quests start with the manticore the
fearless adventurer you mean
corey she's over there quick somebody
help me these griffin nuggets were
supposed to go out minutes ago
that's the man's accord you guys
are in trouble big time get in the
vehicle i'm escorting you home i'm
giving you to the count of three
uh okay wait what are you doing i don't
know
i'm looking for my sons oh they went on
a quest but don't worry i told them
about the map
i told them about the gym i told them
about the curse huh i forgot to tell
them about the cars
what your boys are in great danger
hold on
[Applause]
how are your boys doing oh no
we're dead we're dead we're dead not
great
i can't do it we're not gonna see you
dad you can do this
i believe in you my gut knows where to
go don't you boy yes you
i'm on my do boys just stay out of
[Music]
trouble
is anyone hungry yes starving i'm on it
i'm just going to wait until we get home
where the food isn't decomposing
well la dee da i didn't realize i was
with a bunch of sophisticated
can come in all shapes and sizes that's
why i also feature having some
two-legged children
join them roll it imagine me and our
future children
frolicking this is fun i'm speeding up a
little
i'm speeding up
i think he's getting the hang of it
tommy no those are mr mcgregor's
i swear if it wasn't for me peter just
leave my tomatoes alone you have
everything else honestly my kids will be
so much better behaved go easy on him
as soon as they have a baby we're done
for
maybe we're better off without them
don't stare at the scenery rushing by
look at a fixed point on horizon
[Music]
i love this place what's for lunch
there's a magical place with the ripest
radishes
the sweetest corn it's called the
farmer's market
and if you want an overpriced gift that
will never be used they sell lavender
scented bath bombs
this sounds a bit dodgy i would never
put you in danger
i promise okay i can't promise we're
gonna go and rob this place you know
you're out
we're in run
no let them go my family's in trouble
and i'm gonna get them back the other
rabbits were taken
and the pig in the hedgehog and through
why are you even helping me that's what
a dad does
oh no cottontail just discovered sugar
we had a good
run i'm gonna live forever
[Music]
[Music]
what is this place what's your name
honey
uh i'm joel i teach middle school band
connie go for it
today started out as the best day of my
life
here tonight first shows at seven yes
you know what that's gonna say joe
gardner
i did it i got the gig
must have been sudden for you
oh my gosh
no it's the great before this is where
new souls get their personalities quirks
and interest before they go to earth
meet 22. i
okay look i already know everything
about earth and i don't want anything to
do with it you're missing out on the
joys of life
like uh pizza i can't smell
we can't we can't taste either all that
stuff is in your body
no smell no taste or touch see
okay i get it
wow it's my life
is all this living really worth dying
for
you're still alive can you help me get
back
no way there i am what are we waiting
for
this week what is it 151 000 souls going
to the great beyond every day
and i count every single one of them
that counts
off huh
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the new home bring back
memories are you rolling what are you
looking
at
let's give them a great show okay i won
and only
why do they want an angry gorilla anyway
you're a silverback
he terrified humans oh
you're not terrifying
who's that my sister where's your sister
now
i don't remember memories never leave us
they just get out of reach whoa
did you draw all these a gorilla who
draws
what is it don't tell me don't tell me
it's a lonely haystack
on a late summer day
it's a beetle can you tell me a story
once there was a baby elephant who was
smart
and brave and she needed to live in the
wild where she could be free
does the baby elephant get to be free
[Music]
this painting is clearly a sign he wants
to be free
what about mac he's taking care of me my
whole life
we're family we're in this together
[Music]
for one and only even
i'll just cross the road then why would
you cross the road
to get to the other side
what are you doing here in summerville
anyway honestly
my mom won't say it but we're completely
broke
and the only thing that's left in our
name is this creepy old farmhouse our
grandfather left us in the middle of
nowhere
why'd you bring me up here entertainment
value
what is that i don't know
somehow a town that isn't anywhere near
a tectonic plate that has no
fault lines no fracking no loud music
even
is shaking on a daily basis
under the dining table now
hey remember that one summer we died on
our table
i found this in my living room killer
replica
a replica of what a ghost trap
[Music]
there hasn't been a ghost sighting in 30
years
new york in the 80s it's like a walking
dead
your dad never mentioned this to you
it's just my mom
my grandfather died my mom says we're
just here to pick through the rebel of
his life
wait a minute
[Music]
who are you
[Music]
call it fate
[Music]
call it lock
call it karma
i believe that everything happens for a
reason
come on darling
it has a gunner seat
[Music]
scoob do you realize where we are no
look around man
the clean modern aesthetic the cool blue
color palette
we're in mikey falcon fury did you say
ikea nope
i said falcon theory just like you
oh whoa shaggy and scooby were taken
yeah this blue light came down from the
sky and beamed them
up i can't
i can't breathe i have to assume that if
they were with their friends they
wouldn't have been kidnapped
okay can you skip the emotional
punishment what would some kind of
scooby and shaggy
i don't know but i'd like to shake the
hand of whoever created this
and then you know throw that hand in
prison for trying to kill our friends
he's not a stray okay then what's his
name his name's
scooby middle name doobie last name
dude
[Music]
gentlemen welcome aboard
this isn't about some guy in a rubber
mask i would have gotten away with this
if it weren't for you medley
this is about one of us
[Music]
welcome to the falcon fury
hang on hang on turn on the lights where
are my balloons dede when i say falcon
fury that's supposed to cue the balloons
oh great great timing you might want to
buckle up
[Music]
scooby dooby maybe this can lead us to
our culprit
kinkies apparently he's been stealing
netflix by using his mother's account
that is not fair for the rest of us who
have to pay for netflix you have to pay
for netflix here we go
i guess our new movie is an origin story
every hero should have one
i want the rock to play me never gonna
happen
[Music]
[Music]
so what are you doing out here
there is a legend in the jungles of the
amazon
of a tree that heals all it could change
the world
but if it gets into the wrong hands it
could awaken
a great evil i believe that the legend
is
real and i'm gonna find it what you want
when i do just imagine the lives that
could be saved
i've been looking for this tree longer
than anybody
i've tracked a legend to every village
every island nothing
you're searching for something that
can't be found
but you've never had the key
let's do something that's safe let's go
see some elephants there are no
elephants in the amazon and i don't even
like elephants lady everybody likes
elephants
know this about the jungle everything
that you see
wants to kill you and can
careful they could smell fear i am not
afraid
oh my gosh who brings a submarine to the
amazon
good night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just leave me alone that was a disaster
didn't go the way i planned
[Music]
the yukon is a dangerous place
you never know what's coming
i came up here because i didn't want to
be around anyone
and then i met buck
he was a dog like no other
you've been spoiled
[Music]
and he'd suffered
[Music]
but he could not be broken
i don't know where you came from but i
know where you are now
welcome to the last place on the earth i
should let him have a minute
doesn't look like he's ever seen snow
before
how do you feel about an adventure
beyond all maps we could go
you and i where no one's ever been
before
see what's out there
[Music]
i'm glad you're enjoying this
i never saw him believe in anything as
much as he believes in you
[Music]
what do you say book
adventure of a lifetime
he was sleeping for two days in my bed
there you have it mary that's missile
sweet
you stick to your rooms and your rooms
only
no exploring no talking about i didn't
ask to be here
hello wait for me
i saw you who are you my name is mary
lennox and my uncle owns this house
i'm colin craven my cousins
he wants this house was filled with
happiness
now my father wants me locked in this
room it's unforgivable
i need you to keep a secret i know of a
magical place
where the birds sing for you you need to
see it
we could go outside who knows you might
feel better
hey are you dicken hello
you know what you risk it's worth risk
marriage
this is our garden and it can be
whatever we want
[Music]
follow me there are even more secrets in
this garden
our mothers made this place magical i
knew you were hiding something
if you caused me trouble i'm obliged by
law to have you sent to school
and we'll need to break the law won't we
[Music]
stay away from my son i was trying to
make things better
how's this this garden it's capable of
extraordinary things
[Music]
i'm just not that good with people
there's one thing i'm good at
[Music]
the mission was to find out what they
knew but that's kind of difficult now
that you killed everyone
i just don't think you're cut out for
the intelligence this is your last shot
how's school going oh my god you have
jelly all over your face
i'm definitely posting that on insta is
it too late to homeschool me
are you cia what'd you get in here oh
because she has a camera she might be
streaming
if kim finds out we got made by a nine
year old my career is over what's the
option
kill her make it look like an accident
yeah maybe the stairs
what wow still recording
we can cut a deal i want you to teach me
how to be a spy just to be clear this is
a one-time arrangement never again
i can't promise so at first shooting
range obstacle course
or to walk away from an explosion will i
detect your test i can smell a lie
endorphins release an odor in the
ultimate tell
slightest blink of an eye anything like
this dj i admire all of your tattoos
stop jj i believe you that you've never
taken steroids
damn she's good when you look out there
what do you see
90 civilians minimal security soft
perimeter smiling people having fun
you should try it sometimes
[Applause]
the objective of this exercise is to get
past me a good idea might be to cause a
distraction because otherwise there'd be
zero chance of you
i'm just left exterior
you're a nice guy
what is he doing this looks like the
wedding at the end of shrek
i just wanna break the rules
you are not going to get away with that
no good night good night dad
you're behind your dream stage it's
completely off limits for all dreamers
the dream stages are real wow you can
actually change people through their
dreams
why did they have to move in with us
don't you want to be a real family again
there's literally no insta here
[Music]
nice
so gross tomorrow i'll make sure my mom
removes that thing i
always get what i want three two
one don't wake me up she wants to put my
hamster in an animal shelter
maybe i could tinker a tiny little bit
with her dreams
i mean how am i supposed to whack in
this heat these conditions
[Music]
this is about the sun artemis fowl
you've grown strong son
and smarter than i ever imagined
then take me with you you're all i have
now artie
there's just one very important thing i
have to do
[Music]
authorities launched a worldwide manhunt
for the famous collector
he is suspected to have been behind some
of the biggest robberies ever
dad
hello your family has taken something of
great value from us
return it to me or i will destroy
everything you love
you weren't supposed to see this yet
your father is in a complicated
profession for years
he has protected powerful secrets that
have kept mankind safe from the dangers
of another world
it's time to face your destiny
this is what they call greatness but we
are not alone in this
mulch just a talented giant dwarf and
i'm holly short
your ally on the other side it's
real all right
save my father save the world hope seem
ready tell him we are dead
let's get ahead optimus i'm scared to
death
an army is coming
[Applause]
where do you think you are
i'm the next criminal mastermind
now look around this is what they call
greatness i didn't read much on trolls
anything i should look out for the teeth
they eat people good to know
[Music]
bye